so all here it starts now these are the
same ones that weren't Dunkirk exactly I
was on my boat getting people out but
podcasting this must be annoying for you
because when you start a comedy which
was when honestly I'm not trying to be a
dick right now
no no but you don't have to try that's
the beautiful thing about yet just
essence it's your essence dude you mean
you were at this Comedy Cellar before
this thing was even a place to perform
it correct right right I started in 80
81 81 stand-up and then the Comedy
Cellar came along soon thereafter what's
your opinion on podcasting I love it you
know yeah because um any comedian can
put on his show talk about his ideas he
doesn't need anyone's approval doesn't
need to audition yeah of the corporate
uh yeah well I don't know I think that
the thing about your sister maybe you
should not talk about that right it's
fantastic well how have you that's great
to hear
because I always find comics that
started prior to these you know social
media or just hate the new stuff but
obviously you a successful example of
that have evolved and have learned how
to adjust it but you don't have a
podcast no I don't and I don't tweet I
don't you don't tweet no yeah and I
think it's works against me but I can't
be concerned during the day and giving
stuff up yeah or like following someone
yeah because if I'm following like say
Steve Martin yeah and I see it comes up
I'm gonna read it sir or Albert Brooks
sir or you know some comedian I just met
but that takes little chunks out of your
brain like this you know during the day
yeah and there's something about wedding
ideas sit and ferment and you bring it
up in a stand-up act or short story or
screenplay you're writing or channel it
as an actor maybe yes you know so just
so I'm glad because I'm learning right
now you feel like when I grab this and I
scroll up because I got five minutes to
kill or I'm waiting for the you know
whatever and I see an Instagram and I
see a tweet that maybe that's taking
chunks of my brain that could be used to
my benefit there's nothing wrong with
downtime yeah time just sitting on a
bench if you're waiting for
we're waiting for a friend to pick you
up just to look around yeah and that
will get your phone yeah now no you do
that yeah I mean I don't take my phone
to the gym with me
yeah I'm not there a long time but I
that's one thing I don't I have my phone
with me now but I don't have it out yeah
you know we've had people on this
podcast Alan I'm interviewing doing this
while I'm interviewing that's an
addiction that's and is that someone has
a problem yes that they can't let their
brain just be totally focused yeah
that's it it takes a lot of effort yeah
oh to do a podcast it certainly does and
like say if we're at lunch
and you're constantly looking down at
your phone I don't like it no and it's
not like we have to talk every minute or
I need the attention yeah just chill man
well silence is okay very okay you know
and I in sometimes with you I prefer it
you know yeah it was it allows see now
if I've been looking at my iPhone I'd
missed a call go out with gold man I
think it's awesome this is why you can't
say that because I'm on the podcast you
invited me here so you can't say oh
we're here you know it is fun it doesn't
work it's like the the Don Rickles story
hate Frank Sinatra can you come over and
say hi and right it's basically what I
just did
you just came from an audition not an
audition later diamond if you thought
Alan dressed up for this podcast and you
were poorly mistaken uh it was a
callback callback but the audition I
were the same same thing yeah okay so if
you get a callback that means that they
liked you the first time well you pretty
much play it exactly the same both
outfit both the the acting attitude all
that yeah unless you unless you get a
note a bright no they said we want the
same thing gotten to meet put a little
business in I did that there was no
dialogue nice I was was it this lovely
young girl tell me about huh and the
first audition I was hoping to get
paired with this girl I got her and it
was great too
yeah so yeah you know it's nice but is
it funny it was it was like middle-aged
guys yeah and young women yeah because
it's a father-daughter can you tell me
you you you can only disclose certain
information I just don't want to give
anything creatable wait I got it I got
it
in the posturing
of the men at the original audition
talking in voice not to the woman but
knowing that they can hear them these
guys about this job I had to do this
anime and guys do this actors do this
not only at commercial auditions but
regular clashes yeah and one point I
went to this audition this is about
three years ago and these like four or
five middle-aged actors had already gone
in yeah an audition but they were
talking because you know this is when
they see each other and they were
talking about well this and her dropping
what they've been doing they went my
agent said it was a big deal I didn't
think it was a big and I all my soldiers
and I looked and I said oh stop yeah I
know I wanted to I did it I go or I go
are you guys kidding you know because if
I was directing a scene this is exactly
how about self-important [ __ ] actors
they were using their 1974 theater
voices that literally what New York
comics say la people do and you guys are
doing it you know it's like the oh I
how you doing great I just booked a
that's not what I asked you I asked you
how you're doing
you know hey congratulations and that's
your thing yeah I didn't always could do
five of them I mean one guy and this is
weird so I was so true auditioning for
this commercial right after Mad Men I
had pop some a Mexican Tony but it was
on it right so I'm sitting there and
this guy across from me is kind of
trashing this actor who's on a TV show
in a loud voice oh gosh and it's a thing
to myself
geez dude everyone's time is 1 degree of
separation yeah could be a buddy of mine
yeah you know yeah so he's on and on
like this he's yeah every sitting there
then a guy walks in comes up to me Hank
we're each other man I said thanks then
a guy walked out of audition came with
me this is hey great you have a madman
Thanks and then another actor came in
same thing and you could tell this guy
was bombed and then he looked over his
buddy goes hey can you believe we did
Jersey Boys ten years ago oh my god and
then they grab a group of us to go in to
get the same direction the other time
and the guy says hey before we start
Ally great job of a so you can tell was
killing the guy you know keep it to
yourself everybody
you were talking about male posturing I
remember I was watching planet Earth you
know that documentary yes yeah so yeah
and it was doing like mating and you're
watching this male bird do all this
crazy [ __ ] like they clean their nest
the bird and they'd ran over the bird I
forget the bird I don't know I know
you're a big bird guy yeah the Latin
name I don't know
are you serious you know Brno okay I got
me again you got me anima on camera I
got to get some humour yeah we have with
spy guys needs it so this bird literally
cleans the nest then it dances and I'm
watching going like what a ridiculous
set of actions this bird has to do to
try to get laid and then you go to the
bar
human bar and you watch what we do and
it's the same [ __ ] yeah you know chest
out talking about success I talked to
some guy last night I just did the
Showtime thing and I was you know they
we made it available I could also pop
over and do the CBS thing super loud so
the girls can hear it's the same thing
oh we're just animals aren't we Allen no
I'm not you're not an animal
you're a civil I'll talk about me on a
podcast yeah you know yeah when is your
birthday on November 30 8th yes perfect
19 but the boat I'm glad I'm glad I
laughed at that it's like when people
ask me my height and I'll say you know
I'm at 6:14 yeah that's a good one 9
1954 you don't have to tell me at 9:19
you don't have to tell me the XIII when
I meet a guy yeah and I thought how are
you and I don't want actress come on ha
ha ha you know
well even I've been very pleasantly
surprised any female entertainment
people I've had on this show happily
just to tell you they're 8 I don't think
it matters and doesn't matter are you oh
yeah it does it does for acting it does
and and for writing I know you know men
don't do it yeah it's don't talk about
your age ok well I hope you can help it
but you just told me you're better yeah
I don't care because I'm an actor yeah I
look my age yeah you know right I got it
got it I have a buddy of mine who looks
12 years younger than he is and he's
like my age he looks like he's maybe 50
yeah so he doesn't talk about it he's
not an actor but yeah I got I know what
we're birthdays like growing up that's
September 19th where where'd you grow up
Miami so bonus st. Louis raised in Miami
thanks and thanks for just trashing my
home well Miami is what is just like LA
and that it's a wonderful awesome place
but as soon as people here they're they
always have a negative reaction it's
like why it's an awesome place this is
in the 60s okay okay tell me about it
yeah it was great okay
rode my bike all year mm-hmm you know it
rained you know sure but it was fun I
enjoyed it we had I was a Catholic so we
lived right near the church in school
that sounds raised in a parish it was
like a community okay
we had woods out behind the church so me
and the ruddy kids we'd go out to the
woods build forts you know go swimming
in the swimming hole then we had that
last generation they could do that they
could do that and this was before the
Catholic Church had really started to
crumble right oh yeah yeah oh yeah
everything was safe oh my god yeah and
Kennedy was elected yes so Catholic
president right yes it was like come on
yeah we are chosen people man that I
didn't realize because I just watched a
documentary on Jeff Kane if you're not
familiar with what happened in JFK
there's a lot of information out there
but that was a big confirm it yeah that
was big for the Catholics oh well I and
I've told the story in podcast pelea
shared on this one my father pulled my
brother and my sisters out of school in
the middle of the day on November 18th
on a Monday or Tuesday and took us to
the airport off to the side there's a
field a lot of protesters there and in
JFK we saw JFK and Jackie and my brother
was able to sneak up and shake his hand
Wow and afterwards it was on a Monday
yeah is they that Friday he was
assassinated holy [ __ ] oh that was huge
okay that was a um you know no one could
explain it yeah you know God because I
bought it I was in fourth grade yeah God
takes care of us got up yeah you're good
you go to heaven yep good say your
prayers up and then Kennedy gets shot
Walter Cronkite the priests and nuns my
parents no one can explain yeah well why
God what this happen yeah you know if
he's going to watch me crossing the
street and he's not going to you know
he's going to let our president
into a convertible yeah you know we
crazy to think about so when I look back
at that time that's when the apathy said
it yeah early in school and care I
didn't buy it even though I still went
through with it
as I look back that changed me you know
in my perception are you do you still
practice no no no it's hard to meet a
stand-up comic that really fully
practices a religion yes why is that arm
I think as you get older you and
especially a comedian you're used to
making up your own mind following that
you know the beat of a different drummer
and you see the world yep and you think
you know I'm spiritual I believe if your
higher power I believe in energy to me
that's God okay so I still pray okay but
it's not to to the Jesus conjurer it's
to just life in a love energy and that's
kind of my thing I met at a you can't
pray to energy though no but you can
send energy yeah you can you know it's
just like if I see you when you you know
you're going or you tell me a family
members going to yell Hospital I'll say
a little prayer yeah yeah sending some
some by hey I hope you know whoever you
know is going to be okay that's all
Phibes it's just and it's not it doesn't
like go out dddd effect but the fact
that you stop yeah and you take that
moment yes that's it that's what it is I
I agree with you I think it helps when
you send whatever we want to call prayer
meditation intent energy it also helps
just to get us out of our own brain
think about someone else for a second
right like stop thinking I got a bad
haircut or I didn't get the thing know
someone's you know think about someone
else for a second I was much more okay
with prayer once I changed that word to
meditation reflection prayer scares me
because I grew up Catholic and and they
just beat the [ __ ] out of me you know
yeah emotionally and guilt and shame you
came up in the 70s I came up I was in
the 80s yeah yeah why 20 years before
that yeah
it was I mean forget about it I wish I'd
come up in the 80s man I know you look
at me when I take all these heads yeah
this year is a little bit longer than
this year yeah and I'm not kidding
because they used to drag it yeah they
used to pull ya hair and my left ear was
homies on the aisle
you know that's terrible the nuns are
terrible
you're bad people no and we had a lot of
good nuns and here's the young I worked
in a rectory when I was 14 15 answering
the phones okay great priests yeah some
of the finest men I'm sure
growing up were priests so when priests
you know now they had this well-deserved
reputation yeah the Catholic Church is
leaded yes turn protected that yeah yeah
we're generations you know so that's
kind of frustrating too but someone said
oh did you send say 10 Hail Marys and
that makes everything better
I said no but if you sit down and you're
intent and you say 10 Hail Marys or 10
our fathers
that's meditative it's slowly Sherm if
you really say those prayers a mantra
yes that's an ohm or you know if you say
the whatever grace before a meal that
isn't you know anyways yes interesting
we we've gotten off topic as we are
supposed to on this podcast it's crazy
that's what it is off top topic where's
Bertha it's just what's the name of this
show worst birthday yeah so let's talk
about your worst birthday September 19
1954 right how many years passed until
you really feel like you had a worse
birthday um you know there was some kind
of birthdays like we get a party mm-hmm
one year in the next year not just a
family party right so my parents know
you had a party last year I know I
didn't know but you know money was tight
girls so I let that go really didn't
have a bad birthday you know but in
sorry that's the podcast thank you
everybody
great coming by we've got who do we have
coming in now what how many siblings did
you have I had three okay one over
brother two younger sisters middle child
okay yeah perfect there we go perfect
for showbiz yeah yeah yeah there's
another thing for showbiz that and it's
on other podcasts but you know well
apparently what I've learned from Alan
is that we need to really listen to as
other podcasts right really do them um
worst birthday 26 years old okay
girlfriend in New York
okay uh where were you living at the
time uh Hell's Kitchen nice tell me but
I mean that's changed right you won't
tell you about that of the worst
birthday no it hasn't changed
I want it hasn't no there's nice
eateries okay do you know I thought just
gays gays lived in Hell's Kitchen no no
no okay everybody was in Hell's Kitchen
yeah you know and Chelsea is more of
that but still it's you know gays are
everywhere now it's not news like it huh
I know I can't care for the fun
so why would you want to get rid a
hitting that was a joke Alan because I
raised the war for food entertainment
style
thank God lean yeah I mean yeah yeah do
I know a guy who is a comedian gay kind
of dirty is that right yeah I mean like
like hygienic mechanically and fastening
I'm like dude you're gay you're yeah you
should be ashamed of yourself
you know Hey right it was anyway uh so
she you're 26 and I'm going down to her
girlfriends brownstone she had a girl
for years older than me 33 it's like
she's opened me up sexually
culturally wait wait wait this is the
girlfriend or a girlfriend okay she's 33
year 26 and she's opening you up
sexually yeah okay like the last couple
years it's really nice
I'm sure yeah and this is in the New
York Evan DS no this is in 8080 whoops
and 22 if you're born in 54 this was
eighty eighty one eighty you haven't
even started to stand up yet kind of I
had a partner okay but uh aspiring sure
okay and I go down to her friends
brownstone her friend kind of likes to
swing and I know she would had talked
about it Wow so I'm expecting a little
three so yeah in hopeful birth bakery
and walk in surprise it's a surprise
[ __ ] there are people there who you know
I like and love my she had set up my
roommate had worked with her and I some
Siham with my roommate Ryan my room and
my girlfriend but turns out they were
just behind my back so I was totally
surprised was night when I go okay after
like 10 minutes can we get these people
a day yeah but we don't have a threesome
so we spend a night there the girlfriend
isn't there our girlfriend is that the
one that owns the poem by the way ladies
and gentleman you're at home and you're
not living in
the or karela you may not know that a
brownstone is one of the nicer
apartments you can have in New York it's
a single building but it's like amazing
yeah do people don't have these no yeah
now there are 15 million right x-act
then it was like a mill yeah be yeah um
if it was renovated right if not it was
250 right and you've got it it flipped
they did it this is a different show now
yeah so we spent a night and then her
friend comes home and lying in bed naked
and I get up because you not to put your
clothes on here we go
and her friend comes in hi I hadn't met
her before I meet her naked you met her
naked yeah and you're in her bed yeah
with your jollies incredible bed she got
from India with it's like covered on
three sides with these little shelves
woodcarving you remember that oh god
this bed was phenomena 30 years ago 40
years oh yeah yeah this is not 30 you
know whatever six seven years ago wait
this is not the math show a lot of
different shows um and so she kind of
sits on the bed and she's like they're
both kind of tickling me a little bit
but talking and then she takes this
string she had like these sweatpants on
and wraps it around my penis and I guess
and I'm like let's get going here now no
nothing happened I mean is we started
and I I want to get my not here yeah I'm
down six yeah young man yeah and then
finally later with my girlfriend at the
time we did another essence which was my
first it's the same that day the
Dolphins beat the Jets together the
Super Bowl so that's what I remember so
that day so should I just remembered the
birthdays I want these people out of
here yeah I want to get high yeah and
and my girlfriend I at the time we're
having just this great sex yeah always
an adventure yeah you know I think it's
this is a perfect look into the male
psyche someone threw you a party there's
people there and I appreciated it was
organized by go this is lovely wow this
means a lot now can you go exactly it
was like what what what most people
would just be happy there's a party
there's thought there's cake but you're
literally thinking I thought I was gonna
have a threesome and you didn't know it
was a possibility yeah but it was just
you know I'm one holy
I always hear so nice in that you know
it was very mode maybe an hour later I
one of them I'll tell me about this rope
around the [ __ ] thing it was like a
string from a drawstring for sure the
woeful what's all going what's that
doing just I don't know I knew to me
who's the first move
I've you know long shooting yank it off
yeah line yeah uh why why is it that we
want this threesome so badly is it
because two is just better than one
no because it's you all right I was
twenty six times you know I had been
with women you know probably for a good
eight years sure I'm not all the time
but sure and you know I thought you know
I only two girls thanks that's got to be
great yeah and if it's not I'd like to
find out yeah right right
um but then I did my girlfriend like
after that period she was if you find a
woman that you know likes women who
wants to get into bed with us bring her
home
and by the year later at last woman I
took a year yeah yeah and I didn't like
good you know hey you won't have the
reason I mean that's that's yeah it was
just one when I was having an affair
with okay and she's she came over and it
was perfect
yeah I didn't have to choreograph right
nobody had to say Oh movie your elbows
up right he just unfolded they got into
each other they both got into me it was
it was so erotic yeah it's so beautiful
yeah beautiful and the dolphin is just
yet that's when AJ do he got that
interception you don't have to tell me
about it during this strike here so I
guess it was 81 they you do have to
there needs to be a lot of confidence in
the women that you to just be okay with
you bring home another woman right yes
might well my girlfriend like I said she
opened me up sexually very liberal very
open-minded and then missus I think they
forget her on the show no no because
something else happened if you want to
keep going okay and then the other woman
I met were in bed I said you know I felt
her out how did you feel about it wasn't
like I surprised her right right because
now I'd really be into that and I won't
give you the particulars yeah well after
the show
sure but it was beautiful it was great
alcohol and drugs involved no maybe a
little
nobody was under the influence really
maybe a little hot little pot but you
know the excitement yeah of two women
naked you what do you need no I agree
with you that's the drug you know that's
the drug somehow Allen chips and somehow
ladies and gentlemen Allan Havey has
turned his worst birthday into all the
different threesomes he's had no this
was I've only had one Ford my life for
in your life yeah and they all happen
organically I love it well that's the
best way they should happen yeah yeah
one time in Seattle just to one picot
and I couldn't get it up yeah yeah
because I was like overwhelmed I was
surprised and they were very
understanding it wasn't like an alcohol
thing it was just no it was just too
much okay I was overwhelmed yeah and
like there's a young guy out there oh
man what do you care you know it's it's
you know performance anxiety or you high
ever I appreciate you being honest and I
I think women I'm sure I can't speak I'm
half of females but we really have a
gauge in between our legs and if we get
too emotional too excited or whatever it
can become a problem
yeah or you just wiped out you just
wiped out or just it's too like
overwhelming yeah like oh my god yeah
that's a lot going on I mean you're on a
bus and it gets hard like where were you
know I'm on dude
yeah I did watch the commercial and I'm
rock hard you're in coach in the middle
seat no so what's the boner for you know
oh it's true Alan what is and this is
the only guest I've ever had where maybe
the worst birthday could also be the
best birthday well it it eventually
turned into that's what I wasn't a
birthday right I mean I'm thinking
that's the worst birthday I had that's
great Blaine I was a surprise party yeah
you know so that's pretty good have you
had a surprise party since thrown for
you no yeah no and my wife and I my wife
would kill me and I asked each other
yeah we would never do that
surprise in any way it seems like people
don't want a surprise party we had a lot
of worse birthdays a surprise parties
really what is that we like
Danone right we don't like the unknown
it you know in certain ways hey surprise
your work people yeah you know do
something that's kind of nice okay so
riff listen there are people out there
who feel and no one cares about yeah you
go to that you're coming up in your
birthday well you know what's my wife
about surprised and everyone comes out
we all love you
excuse me yeah that's a beautiful thing
yeah people that need it I don't need to
I don't need it I'm gonna be I like
being lonely well I also think comics
get a lot of validation we get the
affectionate attention we need when
we're on stage it's a beautiful thing
right we get to do to 15 minutes is all
I really need is just for people to be
staring at me and that fills me up for
the rest of the day or week at around
the age of 50
yeah about 12 years ago coming up on 13
I realized I don't need not that I
needed it but it was it was a gauge of
being a good comedian I well I take
pride in my work
sure and I like to do a good job it's
like every laugh and every applause I
get after this is gravy
yeah so for the last 12 years I don't
need it you're just skating on yeah I'm
just doing good work and I still like it
when I have a really good set but it's
not like yeah yeah and yeah maybe that's
amateur that's just a maturity and in a
composure and a calmness of successes
you've had growing up because watching
you perform what I love about watching
performing and and you know we'll make
sure to edit this part out is not you're
just free up there like it seems like I
got some material I'm going to do that
maybe oh no something's happening here
we're going to go to that like it
doesn't seem desperate like some of
these comics it does like I got a crush
I got a crush I got to go to this bit
let's get to this bit and you know at
the comedy magic club is where I met you
and where I started watching you do
comedy it's really the only place we've
seen each other that's it and that
actually I think it's probably let's
let's keep it that way
glad maybe a good you told me I won't
put a college in it yeah I forgot I need
Allen for something no but you're very
free up on stage and what I think I'm
hearing as you weren't always that way
um no I'm certainly not at the beginning
it was more
presentation because they came from
theater background share I was a theater
major and I took a lot of those values
into it and when I started to loosen up
a little bit like it's right after my
dad passed away maybe four because I was
here lamp thank you and it was a long
time ago but still was like someday I'm
going to be there and I go what am i
holding back for why not I just have a
little bit more fun yeah and be push it
a little bit more yeah and that really
opened me up as a comedian I love it but
when I going on hermosa I get nervous
of course and not like all you gotta
kill be just like you know ya got
butterflies and stuff like that and
sometimes I don't know what I'm doing I
mean I definitely have a set list sure
is I have like safety buoys arrow too
sure but if I see somebody and something
comes out of my mouth and it gets a
laugh I'll go that way
I never heard it described as a safety
buoy and I love that you know I think
that's a great a great way the first
time I did it
set it safety buoys saves it watches are
worth that now that's how organic you
guys want to see life is yes II oh
there's a buoy over there I'll go hang
on uh it's it's it's fun to watch you
perform because of that but it's also
more exciting that at any age when you
do stand-up comedy it still gives you
butterfly it's not exciting like yes a
lot of people don't get a butterflies
from their job yeah not cool a lot of
comedians don't get both ways they're
kind of burnt you still do it they're
still good yeah but you just kind of go
into the and that that comes from now
but you got to be in the moment in my
opinion that's what gives it the
excitement epsilen hey V where can
everybody find out all about you where
can they see your you on Mad Men as I
assume it's on that man
yeah Netflix you're right you know
that's a great thing about if you do any
television show it runs forever that's
amazing so great so yeah you can go on
where else Allan Havey calm there we go
if you want to go there go on my IMDB
page see you know you can see all my
credits there and stuff and you'll be
performing in New York Labor Day right
every day weekend Oviatt the commerce
over September 5th okay and village
underground in New York fun 8:00 p.m.
it's my show there'll be a couple
comedians on there but I'm going to
headline I lied I love it yeah it's a
great and they've been great to you huh
fantastic here's the key start when they
open yeah
you like you do a really good job for 30
you know Sears yeah and they'll still
book you yeah that's that's a good
advice for a comics out there start when
the one of the best comedy clubs in the
world opens and be hilarious for 30
years exactly anybody there's and be
effective on stage and just be a nice
guy offstage that's important to us yeah
I haven't always been that when I was
younger and because I go to a club and I
was going people and talking and I
talked to people but I kind of was a
little brusque because I was nervous
about turning on so I kind of got a
reputation of being a little hard-ass
hmm and it took me 20 years to get rid
of that record when I met you you didn't
you weren't that way so well yeah but
you could you figured a nine years ago
right yeah yeah ten years ago Allan
Havey everybody thank you for sharing
your worst birthday which is basically
you [ __ ] two girls at once that's as
bad as it gets man that's as bad as it
gets a no it didn't happen on my
birthday I understand I got my worst
birthday I understand I understand thank
you for being here so nice to be married
oh great